gingerbread Christmas trees Santa Claus
and a post office for wish lists these
are all staples of a typical German
Christmas market but where do these
traditions come from
Claudia van Gartner is asking precisely
that question her new book alice mitosis
or it's all a myth looks at the origins
of German and European Christmas
traditions question one this one's for
the kids where does Santa Claus come
from these youngsters agree definitely
the North Pole well I know the red
clothes were definitely brought in by
coca-cola it's true that a coca-cola
advertising campaign in the 1930s
popularized the image of the plump
bearded Santa Claus we know today as for
his home town many people say that sort
of an Emmy in Lapland the city then
officially registered itself as the home
of Santa Claus in the European Union
devine Oxman bought it off kind Santa
Clause definitely wasn't created by
coca-cola and he doesn't come from a
North Pole either
he's a relation of st. Nicholas who
became part of a Dutch tradition that
was taken on by America when people
emigrated there and from there they just
spread question - is Christmas really a
celebration of love it's a celebration
of love but it's stressful it's
stressful at first but then it's a
celebration of love according to a study
21 percent of Germans argue at Christmas
major causes of strife include
decorations who's doing all the work or
even where to spend the holidays but
there is some truth to the idea that
love is an important part of the holiday
nine months after Christmas more babies
are born and in any other month so there
must be something in the claim that
Christmas is a celebration of love
question 3 does Christmas make us fat
I'll fight you definitely get fat at
Christmas the food we eat has so many
rich ingredients nutritionists agree
that the unsaturated fats and Christmas
treats are unhealthy but it seems most
people don't go too over-the-top on
sweets at Christmastime Christmas
doesn't make you fat according to a
British study which says men and women
only put on about 400 grams other than
that Christmas treats are healthy
ingredients like whole grain wheat flour
almonds and nuts are packed with energy
and they also help soothe the nerves
when it comes to gifts the cliche state
that women like jewelry and men like
gadgets but what the German men and
women really want a scooter into camera
jewelry a track vehicle a PlayStation 4
according to a consumer survey German
spent 290 euros per year on Christmas
gifts on average but toys jewelry and
gizmos aren't the most popular present
but in getting with Christmas presents a
good old-fashioned book is often under
the tree for most Germans it doesn't
always have to be jewelry for women and
gadgets for men lock fit in man silence
question five wider Germans always give
presents on the 24th of December future
says two born yet but so what don't know
most European countries give presents on
the 25th of December but the Germans
just can't wait that extra day
I'm Josh Weiss kind of an Jesus no one
knows when Jesus was born but at some
point the church set the date as
December the 25th but in Germany people
used to spend the time before going to
church in the pub as a result the church
services were a bit too merry for the
church's liking so they brought the
services forward in some places gotta
since father Luke and that's why father
Christmas will make his deliveries in
Germany on the 24th of December as usual